Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
Telling new researchers that you can tame SCP-682
with a rolled-up newspaper and a tummy rub.
When you’ve been alive for as long as Dr. Bright,
with the knowledge of eternity stretching out
before you, you can watch every movie and
show, play every game, and read every book.
That’s why Dr. Bright sometimes resorts
to more esoteric methods of amusement.
Such as feeding the newbies little white lies
about anomalies, like telling them SCP-682 can
be tamed with a rolled-up newspaper and
tummy rubs, like a misbehaving puppy.
Which must have seemed really funny
until six new researchers got devoured.
And considering what a nightmare employee
turnaround is at the SCP Foundation already,
losing employees for a reason this stupid
really didn’t sit well with the O5 Council…